ككره ثلج متدحرجه تتفاعل قضيه الاعتقالات
التي شهدتها تونس بعد اعتقاد ثم سجن
شخصيات تشمل السياسيين ورجال اعمال ضمن ما
تسميه السلطات التونسيه قضيه التامر على
امن الدوله بدات الاعتقادات السبت الحادي
عشر من فبراير الجاري بمداهمه قوه الامن
منزل الناشط السياسي والعضو السابق بحزب
التكتل خيام التركي واعتقاله دون توضيح
الاسباب في اليوم نفسه اوقف الناشط
السياسي والقيادي السابق بحركه النهضه عبد
الحميد الجلاصي وطال الاعتقال رجل الاعمال
التونسي المعروف كمال لطيف بتاريخ 14 من
فبراير اوقف الناشط السياسي الازهر
العكرمي لكنه احيل على قاضي تحقيق مختلف
وتواصلت سلسله الاعتقادات بايقاف عصام
الشاب الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري ثم
التحق بقائمه المعتقلين القياديه بجبهه
الخلاص شيماء عيسى والقيادي بالجبهه جوهر
بن مبارك يوما بعدها
احدث الاعتقالات رضا بالحاج القياديه
بجبهه الخلاص المعارضه والمحامي غازي
الشواشي الامين العام السابق للتيار
الديمقراطي وفق عناصر من هيئه الدفاع
تمحور التحقيق مع مختلف الشخصيات حول
اجتماعات شاركوا فيها ونظمها النشاط
السياسي خيام التركي بشان الوضع العام في
البلاد كما تمحورت اسئله التحقيق حول
اجتماع عقده التركي مع دبلوماسيين
السابقين ولم يرد حديث حتى اللحظه عن
اسئله مرتبطه بالتامر او الانتماء لتنظيم
ارهابي او محاوله اغتيال رئيس الدوله وهو
ما تواتر في وقت سابق قرارات الايداع
بالسجن ليست قضائيه بل سياسيه بحته وفق
هيئه الدفاع وهو مدفعها الى مقاطعه الترفع
احتجاجا على ذلك والانتفاء ابسط شروط
المحاكمه العادله وللتذكير وخلال زيارته
لوزاره الداخليه اكد الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد ان تهم الموقوفين تتعلق بالتامر على
امن الدوله معتبرا
واجبا وطنيا دانت جبهه الخرس المعرضه ما
وصفته بالمعامله السيئه والمهينه
للمعتقلين السياسيين وقالت انها لن تنال
من قناعتهم ولن تزيدهم الا تصميما على
مقاومه الاستبداد والدوده عن الحقوق
والحريات
ونظم الحزب الجمهوري وقفه تضامنيه مع
امينه العام عصام الشابي وبقيه المعتقلين
رفعت فيها شعارات تندد بما يصفه بالانقلاب
ودوله البوليس ودانت حركه النهضه بشده ما
اعتبرتها توسعا لحمله الاعتقالات
العشوائيه ضد رموز المعارضه ودعت للكف عن
محاوله تحويل البلاد الى حاله امنيه
تمهيدا لعوده الديكتاتوريه
وتعليقا على الوضع العام في البلاد قال
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اتحاد الشغل سامي
الطاهري ان تونس في خطر وان منظمته لن
تقبل بالاستبداد وستحاربه وتحاسبه